um
while we are working on our technical
problems um i am going to read
one of three excerpts this week from
we have it here we actually just
yesterday got a copy of the actual book
in hand a hundred gatherers guide to the
21st century evolution and the
challenges of modern life and man this
just feels really really good to have
this after um you know depending on how
you count um months of waiting years of
waiting well over a decade in the making
so like we said
the penultimate chapter of the book is
culture and consciousness
and we are going to share
three excerpts
from it today and still you know i
basically wanted to read all of it but
we're not we're not doing that uh so
let's begin
let us begin with definitions
these will not precisely match others
definitions but it is important on this
topic to have stated what we are talking
about for our purposes culture we define
as beliefs and practices that are shared
and passed between members of a
population
these beliefs are often literally false
metaphorically true
implying that they result in increased
fitness if one acts as if they are true
despite the fact that they are either
inaccurate or unfalsifiable
culture is a special mode of
transmission because it can be passed
horizontally rendering cultural
evolution immensely faster and more
nimble than genetic evolution
this also renders culture noisy in the
short term before new ideas have endured
the test of time
long-standing features of culture by
contrast constitute an efficient
packaging of proven patterns culture can
spread horizontally but its
consequential parts are ultimately
passed vertically from generation to
generation
culture is received wisdom generally
handed to you by ancestors and
officially transmitted
consciousness we define as we laid out
in the very first chapter of the book as
that portion of cognition that is newly
packaged for exchange meaning that
conscious thoughts are ones that could
be delivered if someone asked you what
you were thinking about it is emergent
cognition where innovation and rapid
refinement occur
conscious thoughts may never be conveyed
but they can be and the most important
and the most important ones are as
consciousness is most fundamentally a
collective process in which many
individuals pool insights and skills to
discover what was previously not
understood
the products of consciousness are if
they prove useful ultimately packaged
into highly trans transmissible culture
we have said before in the book that the
human niche is niche switching more
specifically we argue that the human
niche is to move between the paired
inverse modes of culture and
consciousness
as an example let us consider the nez
pierce people who have lived in the
pacific northwest for many thousands of
years
since they arrived they have inhabited a
rich land and they now have
well-established cultural rules that
keep them safe and thriving their diet
has long included bulbs the storage
organs of plants which do not want to be
eaten
on these lands where the nez pierce came
to live both camus with highly
nutritious bulbs and death camus with
bulbs that are toxic grow
when not in flower these bulbs are
incredibly difficult to tell apart
the nespirus may not have been the first
on this land but someone was and those
first people could not benefit from
names that would make the danger clear
yet they learned the distinction
presumably through trial and error it
was likely a messy tragic process
by the 19th century however when
spaniards were documenting what they saw
among the nez pierce the system of
distinguishing nutritious chemists from
their deadly relatives was nearly
perfect
this is culture
when humans are exploiting a well
understood opportunity like 19th century
nez pierce distinguishing camus from
death camus culture is king
but when novelty renders ancestral
wisdom inadequate as it was as it was
for the more ancient ancestral nest
pierce upon arrival in the pacific
northwest we need to shift to
consciousness
through parallel processing of multiple
human minds our consciousness can become
collective and we can solve problems
that either we could solve as
individuals nor ancestors could have
even imagined
but another way
in times of stability when inherited
wisdom allows individuals to prosper and
spread across relatively homogeneous
landscapes culture reigns but in times
of expansion into new frontiers when
innovation and interpretation and
communication of new ideas are critical
consciousness reigns
that said novel levels of novelty such
as we are experiencing now are a special
danger this means that what is needed
today and urgently is a call to
consciousness on a scale that we have
not seen before
so that's our first excerpt for today
and we are back we are back in business
here tech wise
well let's treat it as if it works and
if not we will resort to
other cameras indeed um yeah so i'm
really excited that this model is in the
world we have talked about it uh at
least once publicly before we talked
about it on a um a discussion with
robbie george uh to talk for princeton
in the spring of last year
but i do think that
humans are
as
my advisor dick alexander famously said
the uniquely unique species and the
question really is what is it about
humans that allows us to be uniquely
unique and i believe that this model is
a strong contributor to the difference
so
uh just to flesh it out a little bit
yeah um
people will recognize that when we say
you know something like uh
what does what is a tufted tit mouse
right we were talking about a particular
species as people remarkably do
occasionally say to us well sure yes i
mean why wouldn't you what is it tough
to do what is this
we're not going to answer that question
here today tufted titmouse is just a
stand-in for
uh any species and in general if you ask
what a species is it comes with a
description of a niche each species has
some set of things that it does and it
can be a very broad generalist niche you
know a uh a raccoon has a very
generalist niche it does a lot of
different things
a little poorly mountain lion is a
little different mountain lion
different populations will exploit
different kinds of prey and so depending
upon the habitat they may look very
different
but for human beings it's very hard to
specify what the niche is because if you
look at all of the various things that
people do
it's tremendously variable and if you
look at all of the things that people
have done while we have been fully
modern people it's even more variable
it's even more variable in some ways in
many ways we're getting we're becoming a
more homogeneous species right in some
ways we are becoming more homogeneous
but
obviously if a modern human that is to
say the physical being can be teleported
into any one of those niches and can
function well so long as it develops
there and picks up
the correct programming to to function
that suggests something very bizarre
about us which is that we are somehow a
creature that upgrades our own software
and that does not mean
improves it it means radically swaps out
one set of software at the point that
you change what it is that you're eating
and what sorts of hostile forces you're
facing switches out the software uh
on mass in order to replace it with a
software package that has been
bootstrapped for the new local
circumstances
and is an amazing capacity so how the
hell do we do it how do we do it and um
dick alexander had a different um
somewhat different although not in
conflict with i would say this model of
um oscillating forces oscillating
selective forces right that they're you
know that we were striving against
effectively ecology dart with so-called
darwin's hostile forces um things like
you know weather and climate and
predators and parasites um and obviously
we still have to contend with those
things there are you know those things
are in the news now right um and then
there was also the effectively social
competition um that uh we became our
biggest competitors we became our our
most dominant competitor and so
sorry we became our own most our own
most zombies so yeah these things aren't
in conflict at all and in fact that's
dick's model and then our model is is
this culture and consciousness but i
should just say dick's model has to
precede ours because stick's model is
really an explanation for why the human
brain got so disproportionately large
and it had to do with an arms race
between human lineages that caused
lineages that could out-think their
competitors to win and basically we all
inherited this greatly and char
enlarged thinking apparatus but
not only is it an enlarged thinking
apparatus it is a thinking apparatus
that is not heavily pre-programmed it is
somewhat pre-programmed we are not
playing slates but it is not fully
pre-programmed and that means there's
room
to swap in a an agriculturalist high
altitude agriculturalist program if
you're you know farming corn in the
andes
or you could swap in a marine mammal
hunting program if you were uh you know
hunting whales in the arctic and that's
a radically different way of being and
it requires very different programming
exactly and so you know we we are and as
we say in the book we are not blank
slates but we are of all the species on
the planet the blankist slates and we
are blanker even than
our two closest extant relatives that is
the two species on the planet to which
we are most closely related
we are equally related to chimps and
bonobos and they are they are
interestingly quite different from one
another
uh but you i don't think it's ever been
tried uh but a prediction behind which i
would stand and and put a lot of money
is that if you try to cross foster a
bonobo with a chimp family or a chimp
with a bonobo family
the chimpyness will persist in the chimp
raised with bonobos and the bonobonus
manoa wishness will persist in the
bonobo race with chimps whereas
if you cross foster
any human being in any other human
culture so long as you start at infancy
um basically all of the things of that
uh of the family in which the baby has
been cross-fostered will come on board
obviously melanin isn't going to change
but and you know facial shape uh
although you know even even some things
like face shape will change as a result
of diet as we've been as we've talked
about diet and different you know you
could at least have different facial
expressions obviously there's huge
explosions exactly but you know but the
language will be different and the
cultural the you know the memes and the
expressions and the expectations
and um therefore to some degree the
periodicity and the timing of events
uh you know you know babies who are
raised with a lot of love but in very
restrained physical situations um among
the tajik for instance which we talked
about a couple weeks ago
walk really late compared to to weird
babies you know
western educated industrialized rich
democratic society bred weird babies
whereas some babies in kenya where it's
you know the encouragement is to move a
lot very early they walk earlier and you
know you could take a tagic baby and
raise it in that kenyan village and and
that tajik baby would walk earlier this
is not in the genetic layer it's in the
software it's in the software layer and
it is
both the fact of the software layer
which you know a lot of this will be
familiar in one regard or another to
people who've been uh watching and
listening to us but the
software layer
is every bit as biological it is a
different way of transmitting
information it is transmitted outside of
the genome but it is not less biological
and we argue
i think persuasively in the book that it
is
subject to the objectives of the genome
and so the question is how does a genome
that is trying to get into the future
and doesn't really care about how it
doesn't care about in what form or
through what behaviors upgrade its
software program so that it can take
advantage of whatever opportunities it
encounters along the way and so we
argue for this oscillating
uh set of modes one which you use when
you figured out how to behave in a
particular habitat and one which you use
when you have to figure out how to
behave in a new habitat whether that's
because your old habitat changed or
because you've moved or because you live
at the edge of a habitat where your
ancestral population developed its
insight and it is this ability which
you know the key thing is that human
beings can do something that no other
creature can do we can actually
faithfully transmit an abstract idea
across open air from one mind to another
and that allows us to do something that
no other creature can do which is to
pool insight and get an emergent
conclusion that is superior to the sum
of the individual conclusions that
different uh different people would have
if forced to to calculate independently
so let's just for stall an objection i
see which is that there are
at least proto-linguistic things
proto-linguistic communications in some
other organisms in which information is
being conveyed but in no other species
is information being conveyed with the
level of both accuracy and precision
that that we can convey it you know
language is several steps beyond what
anyone else has and so
uh you know when when we were in in
college i remember learning about um
actually cheney and safe barth's early
work with uh boys vervets i think it's
vervet monkeys
uh who have uh three different
vocalizations for the three broad types
of predators um that they are at risk
from so they have a different
vocalization for an aerial predator and
this to say a predatory bird that might
be coming or
a terrestrial basically a mammal like a
big cat and then also for snakes
and you know snakes snakes and cats
which are both are both a risk for
fervent monkeys come differently they
can move differently they really do
require a different kind of response if
you were going to maximize the
likelihood that you escaped from it and
so you know they have
three very different vocalizations
suggesting
an understanding of their environment
that is rich and
involved and detailed and accurate and
they can convey that that information
but they don't seem to
be conveying
much beyond this thing is here you know
danger of one of three sorts yeah it is
a it is a
pre-existing agreement on the meaning of
an arbitrary signal
which is very different from an
abstraction and just if you haven't been
through the logic before the fact that
one can say something that one can be
reasonably sure is uh
um
novel right if i say uh potato bearing
conifer right probably that's not a
useful enough thought that anyone will
have bothered to try it out but if i say
it and then i was to ask you to draw a
picture we could establish that i had
successfully conveyed it over open air
because you'd draw a you know a pine
tree with a potato growing off it or
something like that right
that i'm not sure to what end but i
don't know i can do it to no useful end
except that we have established that in
fact we are not kidding ourselves that
we are transmitting abstract thoughts
between our minds that we are actually
succeeding in doing i mean well and not
and not just transmitting right so you
know the and this is this is one of the
um frequent concerns about the you know
the the many ape language studies that
have that have gone on where um many
apes seem to be able to demonstrate
receptive language and to be able to
some degree to use combinatorics to
convey somewhat new ideas
but
that you know that second thing is what
is often called into question the idea
that you can understand that you know
another species of ape as we are uh
could understand language and you know
of course they're working at a
disadvantage not just linguistic um but
uh but because we are you know we're
framing things in in the world that
makes the most sense to us they're
working with the handicap that we have
handed to them assuming that they they
are like us and of course they are in
many ways but they will not be in some
others
but you know how capable are they
actually of innovating new combinations
with the pieces that we have handed them
unclear
and certainly not as capable as we are
right by far not there's a famous
example what i mean and the problem is
any single example could be explained uh
as dumb luck but right i think the
example is from coco the gorilla who
knew a
symbol for bird and knew a symbol for
water and described duck as water bird
right that suggests the combinatorics
but it doesn't nail it down but in our
case the point is transmitting an
abstract idea is the first step to
something that is really the whole point
of the exercise
if i can transmit an abstract idea about
a problem i have seen or a solution i
have imagined and then you can run it
through your separate mind with your
separate skills and without my blind
spots then we can recombine what we have
both come up with and that's where the
emergent value comes from and that i
mean that also
reveals that the the first individual to
be expressing a new idea
maybe doesn't need this but it will be
helped and there will be a greater
chance that they will
want to make the attempt to convey
something in the first place if they
have theory of mind so i would say
theory of mind which we know to be
already present in apes and and baboons
which are not apes but our older world
monkeys
um to to a large degree if you know if
if you don't have theory of mind and you
therefore imagine that everything else
sees the world exactly as you do to what
end conveying new things right the fact
that you have an idea
in your head may feel like okay so i
assume she knows that as well so theory
of mind would seem to be a sort of
implicit base layer as well well
yeah i mean at some level i think even a
shared language makes theory of mind so
utterly inherent right
if i'm talking to you and i say uh you
know
grocery store
right i know exactly what you put
together maybe i can't paint the ex the
identical picture but whether you
imagine a you know a bodega or a
supermarket it doesn't matter i know
that it lands in a certain quadrant and
if i speak to somebody who speaks
mandarin and i say you know grocery
store
i don't know that they pick up anything
right because i just don't know whether
that word will even register as a
familiar one now maybe it does maybe
that's one of the words that is crossed
over but right but the point is theory
of mind
a shared language is a
almost impossibly complex shared theory
of mind inherently indeed and uh and
anyway it creates the basis for
um
for
overcoming obstacles extremely rapidly
right think about what evolution
has to overcome if it functions at a
genetic level in order to innovate the
tools necessary to hunt a new kind of
prey right unless it's very like an old
kind of prey it's going to take a long
time for the program to be modified at a
genetic level whereas it can be modified
in hours if people get into conversation
about
here's what we're doing here's why it
doesn't work and here's what we might do
that would fix it right that's a very
rich conversation and basically it turns
evolution
onto an extreme form of fast forward
which is the reason that human beings
don't have a niche is that we're
actually better off without one because
it means if we happen onto a niche we
can figure out what to do with it
so we're constantly
happening upon new niches through
spatial exploration and creating new
niches through technological innovation
and the like and therefore over time
we find new niches as well so you know
and and you already invoked this but you
know traveling across space and time we
are able to deal with the new niches
that we are either finding ourselves in
or creating for ourselves better than
any other species on the planet
but not quite good enough to deal with
um the rapid change that we are creating
on the planet today
[Music]